[MUSIC PLAYING]
MARK MANDEL: Hi, and
welcome to episode
number 169 of the weekly
Google Cloud Platform Podcast.
My name is Mark Mandel, and
I am here and delightfully
joined by Gabby Ferrara.
Hey, Gabby.
How are you doing today?
GABRIELA FERRARA: Hello, Mark.
How are you doing?
MARK MANDEL: I'm very well.
Very, very well.
Game Developers Conference
is far behind me,
but NEXT is around the corner,
so everything is on fire again.
[FIRE ENGINE SIREN]
GABRIELA FERRARA: Don't panic.
MARK MANDEL: It's fine.
Everything will be fine.
So who are we
talking to this week?
GABRIELA FERRARA:
So this week we're
going to be talking to
Conner Gilbert, product
manager for StackRox.
We're going to be talking
about containers and security.
MARK MANDEL: Sounds awesome.
And then after
that, I get to ask
you the fun question
of, Gabby, how do I
migrate my traditional data
warehouse platform to BigQuery?
How do I do that?
[LAUGHTER]
GABRIELA FERRARA: You
have no idea, right?
MARK MANDEL: I don't
know what I said,
but it sounds really good.
And I'm sure this is a problem
that very many people have.
GABRIELA FERRARA: It is.
It is.
I'll tell you later.
MARK MANDEL: Wonderful.
But before we do
all of that, why
don't we get stuck into our
cool things of the week?
Gabby, what have you got?
GABRIELA FERRARA: Now you
can automate your reports
on Sheets using the data
connector for BigQuery,
which means you can
get your stuff that's
on the data warehouse, Mark--
MARK MANDEL: Oh, nice.
GABRIELA FERRARA: --and put
it on the Sheets automatically
to be updated with Apps
Script and other stuff.
There is a post from Alicia
and Anu, our colleagues,
and they should check it out.
MARK MANDEL: Oh, fantastic.
I didn't realize
Alicia wrote that.
That makes perfect
sense, of course.
So there is a series
of articles that we're
going to go through on
the Google Cloud Blog
giving you some insight and some
direction on various aspects
of the sessions that are
happening at Google Cloud NEXT.
So there's one here called "Six
Standout Serverless Sessions."
That's wonderful alliteration.
"Six Standout Serverless
Sessions at Google Cloud
NEXT '19."
We'll link to it
in the show notes.
I want to highlight
one that I think
is particularly great called
"Where Should I Run My Code--
Choosing from Five
Compute Options."
That going to be run by
teammate Bryan Dorsey.
I know a lot of people
tend to be like,
we have so many things,
and it's so cool.
How do I choose where I
should be running my code?
I think you'll find this is
going to be a great session,
I should say.
But there is also some
other stuff around Knative,
running containers.
Serverless on Google Cloud
is a spotlight session.
All sorts of good stuff
around serverless stuff.
GABRIELA FERRARA: Yeah.
Thank you.
And also at NEXT,
this year we're
offering about 30 topics ranging
from building a better customer
service and automated visual
inspection for manufacturing.
What do I mean by that?
Machine learning all the things.
Take a look at the show
notes about "Nine Sessions
You Must See About
Machine Learning at NEXT."
MARK MANDEL: Fantastic.
Rounding that out, there
is another article called
"Don't Miss These
Must-See G Suite Sessions
at Google Cloud NEXT."
There are about 17
of them in a list,
from small to medium
businesses are
using Google G Suite,
G Suite migrations,
accessibility features.
But I think my
favorite here is "How
to Grow a Spreadsheet
into an Application."
I think we've all been through
experiences where something
has started as a
spreadsheet and ended up
just becoming more and more
and more and more stuff.
But there's how to apply forms,
and Apps Script, and App Maker,
and so how you can iterate
using [INAUDIBLE] forms.
Sometimes it's just a great
way of getting things done,
so I'd be quite keen
to check that out.
GABRIELA FERRARA: Cool.
MARK MANDEL: Probably
worth mentioning, though--
if you're not going to be
in San Francisco for NEXT,
NEXT On Air is available.
So there'll be live streams
of a variety of sessions
and all sorts of
other good content,
as well as extended
viewing parties that
are happening around the globe.
So make sure to check out the
show notes or just Google NEXT
On Air, and that'll take
you to the right place
so that you can see
what's going on even
if you aren't in San Francisco.
GABRIELA FERRARA:
On that note, let's
talk to our guest,
Connor Gilbert.
MARK MANDEL: Awesome.
Let's go do it.
So very happy to have
Connor Gilbert here,
product manager for StackRox.
Thank you so much
for joining us today.
How you doing, Connor?
CONNOR GILBERT: Pretty well.
Glad to be here.
MARK MANDEL: Awesome.
Well, thank you
so much for coming
to talk to us about StackRox,
and Kubernetes security,
and container security, and
all the security things.
Before we get stuck
in there, do you
want to tell us a little
bit about yourself
and your background?
CONNOR GILBERT: Sure.
So I'm a product manager on
the product team at StackRox.
At a small company, that
means dealing with customers,
triaging issues,
understanding their needs,
developing new features,
figuring out the roadmap,
then working with engineering.
So it's really all across the
stack of delivering a quality
product.
A lot of fun.
MARK MANDEL: Awesome.
At a high level, do
you want to tell us
about what StackRox does?
CONNOR GILBERT: Yeah.
So we're a Kubernetes security
company, and what we do
is try to use the power of
containers and Kubernetes
to help customers up
their game in security.
We build a product that
goes across the container
lifecycle-- so
build, deploy, run--
and helps them understand
risk, understand
where they might be exposed,
and detect threats and respond
to them in real time.
GABRIELA FERRARA: What
Google Platform products
do you use for the
StackRox platform?
CONNOR GILBERT: Yeah, so we
have an interesting deployment
model.
We are a security
product, and we
want to run wherever
customers do, so
across Google Cloud Platform,
other clouds, on-premises.
So we use a lot of GCP
products inside of our company.
We run a Kubernetes
Engine cluster--
actually two of them, I
think, on every commit
into our code base for
testing and validation.
We use the Google
Container Registry,
some of the container
analysis products internally
for deployment and
things like that.
But then when we're
deployed, we act
as a self-contained product.
We do integrate with the Cloud
Security Command Center, which
has recently added
Kubernetes Engine cluster
enumeration and
findings tagging,
so helping customers
understand their risk there.
But yeah, mostly internal to
our company, we're using GCP
and really use that to
keep our dev velocity up.
MARK MANDEL: Nice.
So actually, I'm curious.
You said you're a
Kubernetes security company.
What made you decide
that Kubernetes
was going to be the
platform that you
were going to base basically
your entire business around?
CONNOR GILBERT: Yeah,
that's a good question.
And it was definitely
a choice we made.
We started it around
four years ago.
And around that time, containers
were on the ascendancy,
but Kubernetes hadn't
really won the game.
We think really
Kubernetes is the platform
for portable, robust, repeatable
app management and security.
So we've seen
widespread adoption.
We've seen a lot of the
players in the container
space adding support for,
or rearchitecting around,
Kubernetes.
And we really think that's
the place where we can focus,
so we build deep
integrations into Kubernetes.
We think that gives us
a much better position
to help our customers do
a better job of security,
by really using the
power of Kubernetes,
and not going to a least common
denominator of just containers.
GABRIELA FERRARA: Yeah.
And using Kubernetes
on your day-to-day
and integrating it into
your product, what were
the challenges that you faced?
CONNOR GILBERT: So I'll
project a little bit back
into the past.
At my last company, we started
using Kubernetes in, I think,
early 2015, so around the beta
time for Google Kubernetes
Engine--
then called, I think,
just Container Engine.
And there is a bit
of a learning curve.
Now that I've been in this
space for four years or so,
I like to think I've
got up the curve.
But we find a lot of customers,
and a lot of just folks
in the space, community
events, that kind of thing,
where the knowledge
of Kubernetes,
the knowledge of containers
hasn't really penetrated
the entire organization.
So they've started
with development,
or maybe the operations
team has started using it.
Maybe it's in some
stages of the business,
but not in production.
But often, security
is left behind.
So the security
team is often trying
to catch up and understand,
what the heck is this thing?
What are the consequences?
How does it deploy?
How do I monitor it?
Those are the challenges we see
across a lot of organizations.
MARK MANDEL: You said
something interesting as well.
You said, just talking
about StackRox generally,
it sounds like it's both CI
and CD, so just Continuous
Integration and
Continuous Deployment.
But there is an integrated
security aspect to all of that.
And when I think of
security, I'm like, oh, yeah,
just scan my container,
and then I'll be fine.
Like, whatever.
But it sounds like you're being
a bit more holistic about it.
Is that correct?
CONNOR GILBERT: That's
a really good point.
So we call it a full
lifecycle product.
I mentioned earlier maybe
that they'll deploy run stages
of the container lifecycle.
So there are things
you want to apply
in all of those stages
as your app moves
toward production, but also in
the infrastructure underlying
it.
So when you think of making
a holistic security program,
you really have to make sure
that your images are clean,
make sure that they're minimal.
There are a lot of things that
can have downstream effects
in the build phase.
In the deploy phase, there
are a ton of controls
that Kubernetes exposes.
A lot of people don't use
them because either they
don't have any
incentive to do so,
or they don't know about
it, or they find it
a little bit too complicated.
There's another learning curve.
So once you know how
to use Kubernetes
and you know how to
get your app deployed,
maybe you don't want to take
another learning curve up
and learn network
policies, for instance.
So there's things you can
do in the deploy phase.
And then in runtime,
ongoing monitoring
it is important for any
kind of security threat
detection or response.
In addition, there's
that underlying layer
of the infrastructure-- so
securing your registry, where
you're storing your
container images,
securing the cluster
infrastructure.
There are plenty of options for
[? deploying ?] your cluster,
plenty of options for managing
it, including on GKE or just
on GCE.
So there are a lot
of things you can do,
and we try to help people
understand all of those.
GABRIELA FERRARA: You
mentioned monitoring.
It did get a bit
of my attention.
What kind of
monitoring is StackRox
offering for their
customers, for instance,
if someone tried to access my
port 3306 for MySQL or a DOS
attack?
What it is?
CONNOR GILBERT: I'll
answer by discussing
a little bit about how
people run containers,
and microservices especially.
So if you add the microservices
design pattern into the mix,
you're really operating your
application in a different way,
and you're building
in a different way.
So typically, people will
start their container journey
by learning some best
practices and packaging, maybe,
existing apps into containers.
But once they've gotten
past that initial stage,
they'll start building their
app to run well in a container.
So there will only
be one process
running, for the most part.
There won't be supervisors
starting new processes every so
often.
Your app will have one
job, for the most part.
So we monitor a
lot of those things
and then say, well,
because it's a container,
there are a lot of
things that you wouldn't
expect to normally happen.
If you're monitoring
a VM, you'll often
see people installing packages.
There's some system,
then, getting inside
to make sure that
something is deployed
or operating correctly.
With containers, you
often don't see that.
So you can monitor
the signals that
might have been too noisy
in other infrastructures.
So you can monitor those,
and then each report
has more meaning.
So what we do is in our
product specifically,
we monitor the container
activity, including processes,
network activity, other things.
They take on a different
meaning in containers
just because of the way the
apps are built and deployed.
MARK MANDEL: So now
I'm kind of curious.
You've obviously gone deep
on the container space,
but you have a
security background.
Has containerization made
your life easier or harder
from a security point of view?
CONNOR GILBERT: That's
a good question.
I'm in a different
position, having
gotten into the container
space a little earlier
than some others.
Certainly not the earliest.
I found out about Docker
after it was 1.5 or so.
But I do have that background.
And within the company,
we've got people
from ops and security.
I think once people understand
the concepts of Kubernetes,
they find that it helps
them to do their job better.
So often any sort of reticence
is around unfamiliarity.
It's true that there
are applications
that aren't well
suited to containers,
but a lot of applications are.
And once you adopt the
containerization strategy,
and especially
adopting Kubernetes,
you can really improve your
visibility, your ability
to really understand
what a deployment is,
and to monitor it.
Some of those
advantages are just
having all the
metadata in one place.
So I just spoke at BSides
San Francisco few weeks ago,
and just showed on
the screen an example,
actually simplified
deployment YAML,
so a deployment
specification for Kubernetes.
Then it's got the exact
reference to what image
will run, so the exact
file system and code
that's going to be there.
You can have network security
policies attached right
alongside.
You've got the privilege
level, Linux capabilities,
the user that it
should run under,
the storage that
you're going to access.
There's a ton of stuff.
There's even annotations,
sort of an unsung hero.
If your operations team
is using annotations
to understand what
they're deploying,
now you can see them
in security too.
So really, having the Kubernetes
API lets the different teams,
even if they haven't totally
learned all the Kubernetes
concepts, it does sort of gather
a lot of information together
and help people speak
the same language.
We talk about the Kubernetes
API being the language
that everyone can
speak to understand
what's going on in deployment.
GABRIELA FERRARA: Containers,
in the end, are popular now,
and everybody wants to run
their stuff in Kubernetes
because it's the cool
kid on the block.
What questions do
you ask your clients
when they come to you
with an architecture
and want to deploy
on Kubernetes?
What do you ask them?
CONNOR GILBERT: It
depends on really
what your application does.
Some applications will
work perfectly fine
in a managed service.
Some will work fine even in
a surrealist context, a cloud
function or something like that.
We find that a lot of things
that people would run on VMs
can naturally move
to containers.
There are even use cases
where you can use containers
as a packaging strategy, but
maybe not even orchestration,
so some customers will end
up running containers on VMs
directly.
Those are exceptions.
I think most people can use
containers in Kubernetes,
and they will drive
benefit from it.
It's more the edge cases that
would require some extra care.
GABRIELA FERRARA:
Do a lot of people
want to run everything on
Kubernetes-- for instance,
databases, stuff
that is stateful?
Do you get that a lot?
And how do you explain
to them that maybe it's
not a case for that?
CONNOR GILBERT: Yeah,
so I think there's
been an interesting shift
in the marketplace recently.
So we used to have
a lot of people come
and say, oh, you guys
know containers, right?
I need containers.
Can you tell me what they are?
Or, I need Kubernetes.
Can you please tell
me how to use it?
If you project back
maybe eight or 10 years,
I've heard about Hadoop.
I need Hadoop.
Could you please
tell me what it is?
So we used to be in
that space a lot more.
Now we're seeing a lot more
sophistication in the customer
space, knowing what's
good and what's not.
Ops teams are coming up to
speed on containerization
and on Kubernetes.
But you're right.
You mentioned databases,
so stateful applications.
It has been an evolving
story in the community.
I come from more of a security
background versus an ops
background, so I have less
experience directly managing
databases and stuff.
But it's certainly true
that people have figured out
different ways of using,
say, stateful sets, or even
resources outside the
cluster to help manage
their stateful workloads.
That's one example of something
that people might not always
want to put into a
Kubernetes cluster.
GABRIELA FERRARA: Thank you.
MARK MANDEL: I'm curious to know
as well, from your experience
and what you've been seeing,
if there was one thing that you
were like, I just
wish everyone would
do this either across
containers or Kubernetes
from a security perspective,
what would that be?
Or maybe two things.
If you have more
than one, it's fine.
CONNOR GILBERT: If
you look at the things
that containers or Kubernetes
will really helps you do,
one of the main things is
understand what's going on.
So there's a lot of data
in those deployments.
There's a lot of data
hiding and all the specs
that you've given to Kubernetes
for how to run your app,
and how to keep it
running, and all that.
So if people would take
a look at those specs,
look at the options they've
got, and just think about
whether the defaults
work for them,
that would be a huge difference.
So we see a lot of people just
running with default configs.
And that's fine, same
default in a lot of cases.
But you can get
a lot of benefit,
and you can really
leverage the value
of having split up your app into
containers and microservices,
if you take a look at a couple
of the options in the security
context and in the
pod templates that
help you reduce the privileges
that your container's running
with, or reduce the risk that
would happen if something were
to exploit an application
vulnerability.
There's one actually, really
specific one, which is you
can set any container to have
a read-only root file system.
So if there is a command
ejection in your application--
say, this routes one, or things
like that, or shellshock--
if the file system is read-only,
a lot of things that people
will try to do just won't work.
And there are ways you can
do-- you can add a volume
instruction in your
Docker file or mount
the directory in Kubernetes--
that let you have
specific paths be writeable.
But the read-only
root FS can be really
powerful to both enforce
good development practices
and also minimize the
risk of adversaries
compromising your
app and spreading
through the infrastructure.
GABRIELA FERRARA:
Have you noticed
a shift on compromised
applications
since you started with
this security initiative
at StackRox?
Did you notice a difference
between before and after?
Give you an example.
There are some applications
that are really vulnerable.
Usually, you can get in through
malicious HTML, JavaScript,
and sometimes gain
access to the server.
You don't notice
any shift on that?
CONNOR GILBERT: We've done some
research, the internet as well,
where we do some [? honey ?]
[? nut ?] research.
We see what people
start throwing
at containerized applications.
And we've found that
really it makes sense.
They don't know that
it's a container,
so they don't try to do anything
different to the applications.
People do try to attack the
new infrastructure components.
So we've seen some problems
with Kubernetes dashboards
being exposed on the
internet and then
being used to run code.
That's a new threat,
but it can be managed.
For instance, if you're in
Google Kubernetes Engine,
you can just use the Workloads
UI in the Cloud Console
instead of exposing
a dashboard directly.
So there are things you could
do to minimize the new threats.
The old threats that
have really changed are--
I think command ejection
is one of the biggest.
And just the ability
to detect when
something like that happens
is much greater because
of the structure
of the container
and the app in the
Kubernetes world.
You won't find a
major difference
in things like storage
or cross-site scripting.
You won't find a
huge difference just
because it's in a container.
If you've still got
the same database,
or you've still got the same
app, just being in a container
won't change the game for those.
MARK MANDEL: That
sounds reasonable.
Do you see a shift, though,
in where the risk security
responsibility lies?
Do you see some things moving
more to the cloud providers
and less to the
users, or vice versa?
CONNOR GILBERT: It's
an interesting space,
because the responsibilities,
even within an organization,
have shifted.
So in the previous world,
especially if you're not
in a cloud, you may
have a process where
security owns the
internet uplink,
and they own the firewall box.
And if you want to
get your app exposed,
you have to go to them.
You have to write a ticket.
Whatever you have to do,
they're in the process.
And one of the big shifts
with categorization
is that often, developers
and operations folks
are running the entire stack.
The network is software-defined.
The firewall has software
defined in Kubernetes.
A lot of this runs in places
that don't have natural hook
points for security.
Among teams, there has to
be increased collaboration.
Now when you get to
the cloud provider,
there are different
options for deploying
Kubernetes and containers.
You have managed services,
like Google Kubernetes Engine.
You can also run Kubernetes
using open-source tooling
on top of infrastructure
as a service providers,
like UCE, AWS, Azure.
You can do it on-premises.
The [INAUDIBLE]
responsibility changes
depending on which of those
options you've selected.
With Google
Kubernetes Engine, you
can have Google patch
your master infrastructure
and keep that
protected while you're
responsible more for
your applications.
If you're running
self-managed, then you still
have to manage some
infrastructure components,
including the master, including
the worker node security,
a little bit more directly.
But in any case,
the cloud provider's
never really going to know
what your workload is.
So it is something that
you have to do to make sure
that your images are in an
ideal state, or at least
a secure enough state, that you
understand your risk posture,
that you know what
parts of your app
you want to pay
more attention to,
and that you're
monitoring for threats.
The cloud provider
can't really know enough
about your application
to effectively do that.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah, that
sounds interesting.
Flip it around to
squishy people things.
From an organizational
perspective,
do you see that shift happening
in how people are organized
inside a company as well?
CONNOR GILBERT: We do see
some changes in the way
that teams are managed and
the way that people operate
together in this new
world of Kubernetes-based
infrastructure.
For one thing, people have
to talk to each other.
There have been
times where I've been
on-site with a customer, maybe
doing a proof of concept,
and we've had a meeting
together with, say,
the security operations center
staff and then the people
running the
container deployment.
And they're meeting.
They're introducing each other.
They're shaking hands
for the first time
and learning about their
infrastructure together.
Usually this is when maybe the
container infrastructure is not
as mature.
It's a smaller deployment.
But the people do have to work
together to understand this.
And if they've got an
existing tool that,
say, monitors their
VMs, maybe they
do need to figure
out a new strategy.
Whether that means
purchasing a new product,
operating a new
open-source component,
or just understanding where
the infrastructure is,
they do have to
collaborate tighter.
Now, in general, there are
trends around this, too.
So just like DevOps,
there's DevSecOps.
And there are some companies
that have really adopted this.
It can be difficult,
because asking people
to be good at one
thing is hard enough.
To be an expert in three
different disciplines
can be even more
difficult. But the people
that really can do that
are extremely powerful.
And sometimes we do see
DevOps owning the security
of their application.
And that can be a
really powerful match
because they know
the infrastructure.
They know something
about the application,
and they understand
the security posture,
especially if they've
got a product that
can help them understand it.
GABRIELA FERRARA: So beyond
full stack developer,
now we have full
stack DevOps too.
CONNOR GILBERT:
Yeah, there's full
stack infrastructure, too, now.
And you can debate
where the lines are,
but if you're going
literally all the way down,
some people are deploying
kernel monitoring.
They're understanding
Linux kernel.
And they're debugging
API responses
between back end and front end
and some distributed tracing.
The stack just keeps going.
GABRIELA FERRARA:
What do people get
wrong about containers
and Kubernetes
in general that you
think they would get it
right, concepts and
that kind of stuff?
CONNOR GILBERT: I
think some people feel
like containers
and Kubernetes will
solve all of their problems
with their application
infrastructure.
And while they're
powerful tools,
you can't just
turn on Kubernetes
and then have all your
problems be solved.
It's sort of like
the Go programming
language is a bit opinionated
about how things ought to work.
Containers and Kubernetes
are a little bit opinionated
just in what they make easy, so
they make the preferred answer
a bit easier.
So it could be really easy
to run a stateless app.
It can be really easy to get
some services that are, maybe,
auto scaling or that
are easily replicatable.
It can be really easy
to get that going.
Some of the workloads
you mentioned earlier,
like stateful workloads,
it can be a little harder.
You don't get that
necessarily for free.
Overall, you may get a
benefit from centralizing
the management and
really learning
how to keep things going in
Kubernetes for those workloads,
but it isn't just a free,
sort of, we'll take our app,
we'll put it in Kubernetes,
and now we're good.
One of the other things
is around security.
So the name of this
technology, containers,
has two, maybe three,
four, or five meanings
depending on who you ask.
It's been really great for the
nautical stock photo industry.
[FOG HORN SOUND EFFECT]
[LAUGHTER]
So you've got Docker
with a ship or a whale,
shipping containers, a bunch
of other players in the space.
I talked to
[? Varun ?] from Istio,
and he said he spent a long time
with a Greek dictionary trying
to come up with a Greek word
related to ships and came up
with "istío" for sail.
So security also
doesn't come for free.
Containers are still
just processes.
They have some isolation,
but you're sharing a kernel.
And there is some
more surface there
where it's just not
quite the same threat
model that people are used to.
It's not necessarily true
that VMs are more secure.
They also use hypervisors.
They also have problems.
It's important to not just
think of these as little VMs.
It's not the same thing.
MARK MANDEL: That
sounds really good.
So if someone's looking to
improve their understanding
of security and
containers in Kubernetes,
are there any particular
resources or places
they should go to learn more?
CONNOR GILBERT: Yeah,
so the community
has, especially around
new feature releases
for Kubernetes,
really stepped up
to try to explain these things.
So the Kubernetes
documentation is pretty good.
There are also some blogs that
you find on, I think, just
[INAUDIBLE] or something.
MARK MANDEL: I'm sure you all
have some posts, I'm sure.
CONNOR GILBERT: Recently,
I had a post on CNCF.
They've been adding
some Kubernetes content
and some security content.
So I'll be recording
a webinar with CNCF
also about some security
topics that should be recorded
by the time the podcast drops.
MARK MANDEL: If not, people
can keep an eye out for it.
CONNOR GILBERT: Yeah.
And they publish all
the recordings as well.
It'll be up if you miss it.
For specific features,
there are good resources.
So there are some recipes
for network policies
that really explain
how they work.
If you're looking to get
into network policies,
you can do that.
We've got some features in our
product that help you bootstrap
your network policies as well.
But the community does
have a lot of resources
if you've got the time
to get the concepts
and try some examples and really
learn the concepts yourself.
MARK MANDEL: That all
sounds really cool.
Connor, if people want to
learn more about StackRox
and that kind of stuff,
where should they go?
We should plug your stuff
while we have you here.
CONNOR GILBERT: Yeah, so
stackrox.com is the website.
We were very imaginative
with that domain.
We've got some posts up about
Kubernetes, about containers.
There are some talk videos
as well from, I guess,
primarily me, but also some
other folks at StackRox.
We'll be at all the
community shows.
We'll be at NEXT in April,
coming up at DockerCon,
I think, as well
in April and May.
On the east coast,
if you're out there
and you do financial services,
FS-ISAC Conference, the Red Hat
Summit in Boston, Black
Hat Vegas in August,
and KubeCon in San Diego.
I've got some young
kids, so I'm not
sure I'll be at any
or all of those.
But I'll try to
hit some as well.
MARK MANDEL: Awesome.
Well, Connor, thank you so
much for joining us today
on the podcast.
CONNOR GILBERT: Glad to be here.
Thanks for having me.
GABRIELA FERRARA:
Thank you, Connor.
MARK MANDEL: Thanks
again, Connor,
for joining us on the podcast.
Definitely had a
wonderful conversation
about security and containers.
But let's get stuck into
our question of the week.
How do I migrate my traditional
data warehouse platform
to BigQuery?
Maybe it's on-prem.
Maybe it's on another cloud.
I'm guessing I
have lots of stuff.
How do I do this?
GABRIELA FERRARA:
So every migration
experience that we
have [? story ?]
involves three common steps.
First, you have
your data migration,
then your schema migration, and
then your workload migration.
The data migration is the
data that's on your warehouse.
Schema migration, it is
the changes that you do,
the outline of your database
on the data warehouse.
And workload, it's how you're
going to keep feeding that
to your data warehouse.
Google Cloud has built and
launched data warehouse
migration service to automate
migrating data and schema
to BigQuery and significantly
reduce their migration time.
Because before, you had
to do everything by hand.
And now we have a team that you
can consult, see how it works,
get credit, and try it
out to see how it works.
MARK MANDEL: Awesome.
GABRIELA FERRARA: So you
have now an automater, too.
MARK MANDEL: Where should
people go if they want
to sign up for that service?
GABRIELA FERRARA: So
on the show notes,
there is a link about the blog
post explaining more details
of how everything works.
MARK MANDEL: Fantastic.
And I can see here there's also
a form where people can plug
in their details for
qualifying customers
so that they can take
advantage of that as well.
GABRIELA FERRARA: Yeah.
MARK MANDEL: Wonderful.
So, Gabby, before we finish
up today, where are you going?
What are you doing?
Where can people find you?
[EERIE MUSIC PLAYING]
Not in a creepy way,
just in a fun way.
[LAUGHTER]
GABRIELA FERRARA: They can
find me on Twitter, but also
on Google Cloud NEXT.
MARK MANDEL: Be the week
after this comes out.
GABRIELA FERRARA:
Yeah, I don't know.
I think it's next week.
And at PyTexas right
after Cloud NEXT.
[YEE-HAW]
Then I'm doing a tour in Europe
going through a lot of places.
But I'm not listing here because
I don't want to bore anyone.
MARK MANDEL: I'm sure
they'd be delighted to hear
where you're going.
I will be joining you
at Cloud NEXT as well.
Yeah, call out to people.
We will be doing live
recordings at the GCP podcast
booth that will be
on the show floor,
so please come by and say hello.
After that, I will be presenting
at East Coast Game Conference
talking about game servers
and Kubernetes, all
the usual stuff.
And then I'll also be presenting
at IO as well, so it'll be fun.
GABRIELA FERRARA:
I'm so jealous.
MARK MANDEL: It's
going to be good.
Awesome.
Well, Gabby, thank you
so much for joining me
on this week's episode.
GABRIELA FERRARA: Thank you,
Mark, for having me here.
And I'll see you at NEXT.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah,
I'll see you at NEXT.
And thank you all for
listening, and we'll
see you all next week.
[MUSIC PLAYING]